foreign
[Music]
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah in the country of
Norway click on the link and donate now
for the sake of Allah
thank you
[Music]
brothers and sisters and dear friends
I'm here with the champ the one and only
the Beast the one that is un uh altered
an altered Oh you mean like in terms of
gender dysphoria yeah yeah I'm the same
alhamdulillah consistency is key in life
yes so brothers and sisters in a
nutshell this video has been sent to me
Left Right Center yeah I actually found
it funny I didn't finish the reaction
video but it just found it really funny
but this is you thought you do anyways
yeah you know because the thing is well
it's just it's just it's just it's crazy
it's crazy so do you want to watch it so
here we go and you know what's really
funny what's really funny is what
they're reciting yeah and I had to say
I'm into it you ready all right
foreign
[Music]
yeah definitely may Allah keep us on the
right path I mean uh because this is
actually very it's crazy because the
thing is we know that um this is two
queer gay Muslims basically two men who
are getting married
um now the funny thing is obviously
there's a few conditions for in the car
uh to be accepted uh subhanallah so they
don't fit any of them from the from the
hustle is Battle yeah it's for the
hustle and from the get-go this is
invalid so for an action to be accepted
we know there's two things which is that
you have to have the intentions which is
that I ask you for the sake of Allah
something that we as YouTubers struggle
with we should work on uh which is very
important actually intentions number two
is the actions so the actions have to be
according to the Sunnah now we know
nowhere from the Quran the Sunnah
anywhere of this
there is nothing ever has happened in
history
so Allah is condemned not only that
destroyed Nations because of this action
let alone
them doing a Nikia so when you see this
I mean like what goes through your mind
because I don't know if I should love
for Crime no matter there's one thing
the one example that came into my mind
that was like a vegetarian who's so
desperate to cling onto the title of
vegetarian yeah but he can't do the
actions of being a vegetarian so he
tries to
superimpose oh no no I'm gonna eat meat
but I'm still a vegetarian which goes
against the definition of a vegetarian
exactly which goes against the
principles of vegetarian but he still
identifies as a division he still
identifies even though what he's the
actions that is following is not of a
vegetarian and that's the thing Islam I
mean one of the five things that he came
to preserve was family yes yes yeah the
the lineage family and it takes these
things very very seriously categorically
this is Haram it's not permissible in
fact Islam is being praised by many
people that are accepting Islam as being
the last line of defense against this
lgbtv phenomena yeah so alhamdulillah
this is a source of Pride for us yeah
not that Pride Aliyah don't get excited
okay yeah this is like it seems like
certain words and certain colors have
been hijacked as well oh yeah
but subhanallah this is a form of Pride
that we say no we can categorically say
this is wrong it is not within the scope
of Islam it's an aberration it's not
allowed within the religion clear cut
not only that it's not valid so meaning
look it can be I can look at these two
people and be like you know what they
are really being tested and they just
think in their head look the intentions
could be that I cannot down the
intention of someone's heart I can't say
you know what the intentions are they
actually are sadly misguided but they
genuinely think that this is somehow
gonna make it Halal it's not the action
within it very itself is Haram so you do
it in Nikka doesn't make it more Halal
in the sight of Allah nothing has
changed
well exactly and only that we can take
the situation where for example if a man
and a woman is getting married and the
Wali is not there
foreign
okay but in general the Prophet The
Prophet Muhammad said there is no
um so therefore the point is what you
are doing a Nikka you're committing a
man or a woman
for them to at least they can have a
condition that can be fulfilled if the
Father Knows okay
but with you guys in that situation man
you can bring the father that you can
bring whoever you like then the cat is
battled within itself so to these
individuals who are going through this
book I've spoken to many gay people Etc
even in the park last week I told them
look we don't hate you I don't want you
to feel like you can't be a believer you
can be a person I spoke to him and I
said listen please as religious people
we don't have this animosity towards you
we believe it's a sin and we don't hate
this sinner we hate the sin there can be
instances where we hit the sinner too
but that could go with anyone who drinks
alcohol and is proud of it whatever it
may be that that's the key thing exactly
proud proud how proud that you're
broadcasting it to other people so look
many people are you know they may be
going through this but they don't
declare it you know proudly and make
videos and share it to the people
holding a ceremony calling the guests in
that's exactly that's promoting yeah
that's that's dangerous and that some
people can say even leads to cover like
that's a big big problem exactly
broadcast your sins and make it a part
of religion that's actually it's a deep
deep theological that's issue that's
problematic I know there is if you make
it if you say no this is halal you are
basically become a disbeliever so I
think that's it I think it's very clear
uh may Allah guide them and make it easy
that they're being tested everyone's
been tested but it's simple as that you
don't go against the Sharia just because
you've been tested or you have a
weakness a unicaz battle you are
committing zinner uh if you get dinner
you are doing something that you know
it's it's totally impermissible
guide them and guide us inshallah
I mean especially me I think me
foreign
[Music]